that's right well because the spanners  table this is not an all-or-nothing game  right but if you were asking me can I  reach I can tell you right now it's  about with and that right I can reach  and then all the hours that I've been  here to get here and all that I could  have reached a hell of a lot more people  than on reaching right now but the human  spirit is real right like there's a  looks trap and I about a relationship  six seven years most of it digital right  I'm I've had let me just how many people  here have known about me for more than  three years but have never seen me in  person before raise your hand so here's  what I think a lot about I did all those  things technology wise as a gateway drug  to this moment right and now I get to  make it even deeper than it was before  and so because they both work got it  that's how I think about it